so that brown women deserve to laugh yes
yes because in our culture we and we
don't believe it or not I'm a clean
comic in America right but in India and
in a lot of brown Nations women hide and
watch my videos they're not even allowed
to watch what I do like because making
fun of your mother-in-law making even
mentioning your religion making fun of
your husband no you said your husband's
superpower is logic it's like being very
difficult
being married
to Clark who doesn't become Superman
logic is a Superman like you know
something falls on my head he's like you
put too much stuff on it that's helpful
you know what I mean but in our culture
we don't do that it's not encouraged and
like in this whole world I'm the only
one doing something I thought when I
came out from under the stay-at-home mom
thing I was like I'm sure there's
thousands of people doing this because
you feel like everything's being done
and then I looked around like no one's
doing it no one wants you to what